[Musique]
cette planète et la terre elle à 4,5
milliards d'années
les êtres humains ne sont apparus ici
que récemment il y à 1,5 million
d'années ils ont commencé à utiliser le
feu charbon était son de terre cuite
sont les premières traces humaines il y
a dix mille ans se met en place
l'agriculture animaux domestiques terres
agricoles système d'irrigation au
modifier l'image de la planète avec le
temps
16e siècle de notre ère suite à la
découverte de l'amérique la civilisation
occidentale s'étend au reste du monde
les peuples autochtones du nouveau-monde
disparaissent de vastes territoires sont
abandonnés est envahie par les arbres
réduisant la quantité de dioxyde de
carbone dans l'atmosphère xviiie siècle
de notre ère invention de la machine à
vapeur annonçant la révolution
industrielle au milieu du xxème siècle
l'humanité s'est mise à utiliser
l'énergie atomique à chaque étape
notre influence sur la planète se fait
de plus en plus forte
[Musique]
les humains influencé contrôle
partiellement les processus géologiques
moi en tant que chercheur c'est la
principale preuve de l'avènement d'une
nouvelle époque dans l'histoire de la
terre les scientifiques appellent cette
période l'anthropocène personne ne sait
comment notre monde va évoluer mais
l'humanité a une influence réelle sur la
planète et ce processus ne peut être
arrêté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette odeur me hante depuis l'enfance
c'était plus ou moins fort en fonction
de la direction du vent mais elle a
toujours été là et cela rendait la vie
insupportable
stefano vignaroli via la périphérie de
la capitale italienne
de là on ne peut pas voir la décharge
géante située hors de la ville mais on
ne peut échapper à son odeur les gens
vivent avec au quotidien
après s'être penché sur la quantité de
déchets ménagers générés par les hommes
vignaroli a commencé à acheter des
produits alimentaires non emballées et à
préparer ses repas lui même il veut
produire moins de déchets la
problématique des déchets est apparue au
milieu du xxème siècle
de nos jours l'humanité produit plus de
2 milliards de tonnes de déchets chaque
année
on appelle cela la couche mondial de
déchets si vous regardez autour de vous
quelque part en dehors des villes
vous verrez une colline d'ordure ce
philosophe karl
c'est en quelque sorte le symbole de
l'anthropocène
ma la grotta était autrefois la plus
grande décharge de rome
les odeurs qui s'en dégageait ont
pendant de nombreuses années torturer
les habitants de rome
la décharge a été fermée en 2013 une
usine de recyclage des déchets a été
construite à côté de celle ci et les
nouveaux déchets ne sont plus enfouies
dans le sol
mais ce qui a été amené tout au long de
la seconde moitié du 20e siècle est
toujours là dans les collines recouvert
de terre les déchets était différent
dans les années 60 70
il y en avait moins il était plus simple
presque pas plastique beaucoup de papier
principalement des restes de nourriture
ensuite sont apparus les piles les
produits chimiques et usages domestiques
et ce sont des substances dangereuses
les décharges qui ont émergé à travers
la planète sont remplis de matériaux
artificiels qui n'avait jamais existé
auparavant il ce n'est là qu'une seule
des façons dont nous as fait ton la
planète et il y en a bien d'autres
l'homme est devenu un facteur géologie
il change l'environnement géologique à
l'échelle mondiale d'où le terme d'
anthropocène les principaux matériaux
qui ont marqué l'avènement de
l'anthropocène sont bien sûr de nouveaux
matériaux des matériaux artificiels que
les humains ont inventé le plastique est
une très bonne chose
créée il ya le béton qui utilisés dans
le monde entier domine l'aluminium est
partout il ya vraiment beaucoup de
nouveaux matériaux
[Musique]
témoin
il a fallu attendre 2012 pour voir la
crise des déchets à naples être résolu a
longtemps la ville a eu du mal à gérer
ses déchets et ressemblait à une grosse
décharge
comment je voudrais vous parler du tri
des déchets pour nous allons de porte à
porte je suis déjà au courant le tri des
déchets c'est ça vous triez déjà donc
heureux de l'entendre voilà une chose
importante c'est les horaires du
ramassage des ordures
vous savez qu'il ya différentes
poubelles correspondante à chaque type
de déchets près de votre entrée n'est ce
pas oui très bien
vous venez des services municipaux c'est
ça oui oui c'est ça je fous là ce serait
bien qu'on nettoie mieux les rues ça
vous voulez dire le balayage des rues
jour le balayage ça va on a de grandes
poubelles des containers les conteneurs
il y a aussi des déchets tout autour
il ya aujourd'hui dans les rues de
naples des poubelles de différentes
couleurs marron pour les ordures
ménagères blanc pour le papier et jaune
pour le plastique et l'aluminium
ces derniers étant collecté ensemble le
verre et pour le faire
des poubelles similaires mais plus
petites sont donnés aux habitants pour
faire passer naples de son statut de
capitale des ordures à celui de ville
exemplaire dans le tri des déchets
dans la qualité du tri est plus
importante que la quantité de déchets on
ne peut recycler que ce qui est bien
trier c'est pourquoi les citoyens sont
directement impliqués dans le tri
efficace des déchets les déchets
devraient être acheminés vers des usines
de recyclage plutôt que vers des
décharges mais la construction de
nouvelles infrastructures nécessitent
argent et volonté politique le monde
manque d 2 la plupart des déchets sont
donc toujours envoyer dans des décharges
comme celle ci sorte de monument à
l'anthropocène où sont brûlés dans des
incinérateurs de déchets polluant
l'atmosphère terrestre
[Musique]
près des deux tiers des déchets
allemands sont recyclés ce qui permet
une destruction approprié c'est plus que
dans tout autre pays européen
il existe une organisation de
surveillance spéciale qui contrôle la
manière dont les citoyens trient leurs
déchets si nous voyons des déchets nous
nous arrêtons pour regarder à
l'intérieur des sacs et voir ce qu'il ya
dedans
nous cherchons des preuves pour
comprendre qui les a jetés là des
numéros de téléphone à des certificats
médicaux des tickets de livraison
quelque chose nous essayons ainsi
d'identifier la personne qui a fait cela
on note tout pour la retrouver et lui
faire payer une amende un comité spécial
inflige une amende si les déchets sont
un correctement triés la plus faible
amende est de 5 euros et dans les cas
particulièrement graves
elle peut atteindre 100 mille euros un
autre travail de la police des déchets
consiste à maintenir les rues propres
ils prennent les gens par la main
littéralement jusqu'à ce que ces
derniers cessent de salir les trottoirs
on vous aime regarder si votre mégot ne
devrait pas être sur le sol vous voulez
me fais quoi
non c'est moi qui le filme la poubelle
est à 5 m ici non je veux pas qu'on
filme demande d'arrêter de filmer
teysseyré dont je t'ai la cigarette au
sol c'est une infraction votre pièce
d'identité s'il vous plaît non je n'ai
pas une cigarette est aussi un déchet
oui je comprends
[Musique]
entre 5 et 55 euros c'est l'amendé la
plus courante pour un mégot de cigarette
jeté dans la rue à hambourg c'est le
type de déchets le plus répandu dans le
monde entier un mégot de cigarette est
difficile a remarqué et se décompose
lentement et met en nicotine longue et
arsenic
il peut empoisonner les poissons ou les
oiseaux aucun pays au monde n'a encore
réussi à réduire de manière drastique ce
type de déchets
stefano vignaroli qui vit dans une
banlieue de rome près du site
d'enfouissement de déchets a commencé sa
carrière comme militant écologiste avant
de devenir homme politique il a rejoint
le mouvement 5 étoiles et a été élu au
parlement italien
la décharge de déchets ménagers de mal à
gros tas a été fermé mais il reste
encore la question des déchets
industriels et les résultats de l'italie
sont encore pire dans ce domaine il
fatto la donne et les lâchers d'eau
selon des estimations approximatives le
trafic illégal de déchets est évalué à
14 milliards d'euros est l'une des
entreprises les plus rentables
après les armes et la drogue les noms
mais la di stéfano préside une
commission parlementaire qui identifie
les entreprises italiennes qui
détruisent leurs déchets de manière
illégale
habituellement elle envoie tout
simplement ses déchets dans un endroit
éloigné et les brûle c'est comme ça que
cela se passe dans les environs de
naples cet endroit s'appelle la terre de
feu et tout cela est le résultat d'une
dégradation qui a lieu depuis les années
80 les méthodes de la mafia sont
nuisibles pour l'environnement
au lieu de gérer proprement les déchets
industriels
ils ont imaginé un schéma le revenant
moins cher en conséquence ce terrain a
été transformé en décharge géante comme
celle de google est plombée discale
tous
[Musique]
marilena natale et mène depuis de
nombreuses années une enquête sur les
délits environnementaux de la mafia ces
efforts ont aidés à en arrêter un membre
important alors qu'elle filmait son
arrestation avec son appareil photo
il lui a envoyé un baiser ce qui
équivaut à une condamnation à mort par
l'organisation depuis elle vit et
travaille sous protection policière
comme beaucoup de gens dans la région
marilena pense que les décharges sont à
l'origine de l'augmentation des cancers
la manne prenez n'importe quelle famille
ici elles ont tout au moins un membre
qui en concert très haut mais moi ma
cousine est morte à l'âge de 40 ans
detry elle avait trois enfants mis des
petits enfants meurent de l'est s'est
mis à dos et son guide jamais fait
office de mes voisins est décédé à 28
ans il ya un mois c'est vraiment un lag
la fille d'amis est morte à 31 ans
mais comment est-ce possible
[Musique]
église saint paul à kayes vanot dans la
banlieue de naples
[Musique]
les décharges illégales de la terre de
feu font l'objet du sermon du pasteur
morizio patrick chêne l'autre jour j'ai
prononcé une oraison pour un garçon
gharios il n'avait que 17 ans au fond
nous comprenons que quelque chose va de
travers
soit nous prenons soin de la planète
soit nous sommes voués à l'échec parce
que notre terre va mourir et nous
entraînera dans la tombe
la planète et les êtres humains sont
liés si l'un de nous disparaît l'autre
suivra le désastre de la terre de feu a
poussé le pape françois a publié en 2015
l'encyclique là-haut date aussi
il
il suffit de regarder la réalité avec
sincérité pour constater qu'il y a une
grande détérioration de notre maison
commune
si le regard parcours les régions de
notre planète
il s'aperçoit immédiatement que
l'humanité a déçu la tempe divine
[Musique]
l'oncologue antonio marc fellah est
membre de la société internationale des
médecins pour l'environnement créé en
réponse à une augmentation des maladies
cardiovasculaires et oncologiques dans
le monde
il étudie les liens entre les décharges
et les cancers
nabeul est devenu en l'espace de trente
ans la capitale mondiale du cancer
je voudrais rappeler que nous vivons à
l'époque de l'anthropocène qui est
probablement la dernière ère géologique
mais les gains énormes problèmes liés
aux changements environnementaux les
activités industrielles aggrave les
dommages causés à la terre par
l'humanité à la manita tout cela a un
effet délétère sur notre santé le
problème est de plus en plus évident
le 1er novembre 1986 un incendie a eu
lieu dans l'entrepôt d'une entreprise
suisse sandoz près de bâle
l'eau utilisée pour éteindre la 110
s'est déversé dans leur à la plus grande
catastrophe écologique pour un fleuve
européen
soit quasiment plus aucun poisson sur
les 400 km qui séparent balles de match
dans sa note
cela bien sûr déclenché un tollé l'un
était mort et une réaction en chaîne
était déclenché des pesticides hautement
toxique s'étaient retrouvés dans l'eau
qui avait été utilisée pour éteindre les
incendies entraînant de graves
conséquences sont massives d'effectifs
les loi n'obligeait pas les entreprises
à construire des réservoirs spéciaux
pour recueillir l'eau utilisée lors des
incendies
personne n'avait prévu une catastrophe
écologique et l'indignation a été
générale
[Applaudissements]
cette terrible catastrophe a mis en
évidence un problème qui s'était
développé au fur et à mesure des années
après tout le rhin étaient connus depuis
longtemps comme étant les gouttes et
l'europe
parce qu'un pouce gauche dans le port de
rotterdam sont apparus beaucoup de
sédiments qui aurait dû être nettoyé et
brûlé il était très toxique et apparaît
s'est constamment pas seulement après
cette catastrophe
c'était la conséquence du développement
industriel du bassin du rhin après la
seconde guerre mondiale
les autorités suisses allemandes
françaises et néerlandaises ont adopté
un vaste programme visant à sauver cette
primordial voies navigables d'europe
plus de 80 milliards d'euros ont été
dépensés pour construire des stations
d'épuration sur le rat voici l'une
d'entre elles à duisbourg en allemagne
purifient l'eau provenant des
différentes canalisations
le traitement mécanique et biologique
dure jusqu'à 24 heures après lesquels
l'eau retourne dans le rhin
outre été très propre profondeur de
visibilité dont le réservoir de
traitement secondaire et de 150 à 160 cm
très bien dans un hacker généralement à
cette profondeur on ne voit plus ses
pieds donc c'est très bien mais même les
installations de traitement modernes
comme celles ci ne peuvent pas
totalement nettoyée un fleuve
si vous avez déjà jetés dans les
toilettes des médicaments dont vous
n'aviez pas besoin
ils sont très probablement passer par
toutes ses unités de nettoyage mais
malheureusement nous ne pouvons pas
nettoyer l'eau des médicaments et des
micro plastiques
peut-être qu'on y arrivera un jour mais
pour l'instant nous ne pouvons rien y
faire les conséquences de la catastrophe
environnementale de 1986 ont en grande
partie été effacés les poissons sont
revenus dans le rhin mais la baignade
dans la rivière est depuis longtemps
interdite
il est trop difficile d'évacuer
totalement l'impact des hommes sur le
fleuve
c'est un exemple typique de
l'anthropocène en revanche en réaction à
cette catastrophe
la protection de l'environnement en
europe occidentale a progressé les gens
savent que l'environnement doit être
traité à d'extrêmes et en avoir
conscience ne suffit pas et les choses
avancent plus rapidement et de manière
plus efficace lorsque de telles
catastrophes se produisent
la catastrophe écologique du rhin à
changer les mentalités en europe mais la
rivière polluée était au centre de
toutes les attentions en nettoyant le
fleuve les gens nettoyer leur
environnement proche
mais l'humanité n'a pas encore
suffisamment pris conscience de la
pollution des océans chaque année 8
millions de tonnes de plastique se
retrouve dans l'eau nous ne sommes pour
la plupart même pas conscient de
l'ampleur de cette pollution
ce projet de nettoyage des océans a été
développé par des militants
[Musique]
la plateforme n'est pas censé filtrer
que les gros déchets à la surface de
l'eau ceci également mais pas seulement
que la reine vonn avant tout elle vise à
intercepter les minuscules débris et
microparticules définir voilà le
principal problème en raison des
courants et des vagues des particules se
retrouve dans la colonne d'eau elle ne
flotte pas à la surface
l'appareil se stabilise calme un courant
et il devient possible de recueillir les
petites particules se trouvant
normalement sous la surface les
emballages en plastique et les matières
plastiques non réutilisables auquel nous
sommes habitués seront un jour remplacer
par des matières plastiques
biodégradables
mais cette industrie n'en est encore
qu'à ses débuts
300 millions de tonnes de plastique sont
produites par an et grande partie se
retrouve dans l'océan
d'autres fins d'abord les matières
plastiques flottent à la superficie de
l'océan mais avec le temps elle
s'enfonce de plus en plus sous l'eau
jusqu'au fond de l'océan comme dans les
sédiments se forme alors une nouvelle
couche de carbone
ce processus est similaire au processus
naturel de formation du carbone ccs
il ya des millions d'années dans les
sous-sols de la terre à l'époque de
grandes émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mais n'y sommes pas trop cependant
c'est un processus qui va prendre des
milliers des millions d'années donc on
ne peut pas compter sur sa vie
[Musique]
aujourd'hui après une période
insignifiante à l'échelle de l'histoire
de la planète
le plastique a cumulé ces 70 dernières
années est devenu nocifs pour les
humains qu'ils ont eux mêmes fabriqué
malgré son aspect est en cours a plus
dans nos jeux ne sont pas les restes de
plastique qui sont dangereux mais ce
qu'ils produisent green piccioni ce
qu'on aurait produit ces micro granules
que nous pouvons pas voir imprègne les
océans s'infiltre dans les sols pos ma
ville est à l'origine être dans les
écosystèmes la c1 et paul dano de givre
de l'écosystème
les scientifiques donc récemment
commencé à parler des micro plastiques
des minuscules particules de différents
plastiques
personne ne s'était auparavant rendu
compte que ce type de pollution existait
le biologiste russe egor zadar et f
étudie l'eau et la façon dont les micro
plastiques l'affect d'abord les
scientifiques ont commencé à utiliser
des méthodes plus précises pour filtrer
une certaine quantité d'eau et voir ce
qui s'y trouvait ils ont alors remarqué
des particules microplastiques c'est la
première chose
la deuxième chose et qu'ils ont
découvert que ces microplastiques
finissait dans l'organisme des animaux
marins et pouvait donc passer d'un
animal à un autre
en conséquence on peut trouver des
particules microplastiques presque
partout dans les lacs dans l'air chez
les poissons chez les insectes
chez l'homme les déchets que nous avons
produit pour lui notre planète et nos
organismes des traces de l'anthropocène
se trouve déjà en nous
nous sommes entourés de plastique
nous consommons plus de plastique en
respirant l'air ici qu'en buvant de
l'eau il ya donc bien sûr des micro
plastiques en nous mais je ne pense pas
que l'eau en soit la principale source
ils sont devenus omniprésents le 16
juillet 1945 les états unis effectuer le
tout premier test d'une bombe nucléaire
l'union soviétique a fait exploser sa
première bombe en 1949 la grande
bretagne en 1952
en 1963 les puissances nucléaires ont
signé le traité interdisant les essais
nucléaires dans l'atmosphère dans
l'espace est sous l'eau mais les traces
laissées par les tests persiste
[Musique]
nous avons fait des tests atmosphérique
pendant cette période et avons découvert
des isotopes artificielle des isotopes
radiophonique qui se sont propagées dans
le monde entier pendant les tests
nucléaires des traces des explosions
nucléaires et thermonucléaire sont
toujours présentes dans les gisements
souterrains
les géologues y voit une preuve
définitive du début d'une nouvelle ère
terrestre l'air humaine après ce virage
il y aura un long tunnel
[Musique]
maintenant nous sommes à une profondeur
d'à peu près 100 m
[Musique]
cette voiture se dirige vers le site de
construction d'une nouvelle décharge
elle sera unique au monde à 400 m sous
terre
sa construction est un travail long et
méticuleux il s'agit du futur dépôt de
déchets nucléaires sur la petite île
finlandaise d'olkiluoto en mer baltique
les déchets sont les restes du
combustible nucléaire utilisée par les
centrales électriques
alors que certains pays renonce
complètement à l'énergie nucléaire pour
des raisons environnementales
la finlande construit de nouvelles
centrales
[Musique]
ayral il faut gérer et les déchets
ménagers et les déchets radioactifs bien
sûr il est toujours préférable de
recycler mais si c'est impossible il
faut détruire les déchets de manière
appropriée
nous devons envisager ce problème du
point de vue du stockage et de la
destruction quelles que soient les
déchets une centrale nucléaire
opérationnel se trouve à côté du futur
dépôt au milieu des années 2020
les premiers déchets nucléaires seront
d'abord placé sous forme de granules
dans des conteneurs en fer puis dans des
conteneurs en cuivre et placés dans des
trous en béton encore vide à l'heure
actuelle
ce dépôt aura une longévité de cent
mille ans l'humanité n'a jamais
construit de bâtiments destinés à servir
aussi longtemps
il ne faut pas oublier que tous ces
stocks ne peuvent qu'être temporaire
il ne peut pas les jeter quelque part et
dire ensuite
bon et maintenant on les oublie toujours
garder un oeil dessus tôt il faut
prendre des mesures et à un moment
peut-être tout sortir et ou transférés
vers un autre endroit
il faudra faire cela pendant des
milliers d'années
on ne peut pas revenir en arrière les
déchets nucléaires les déchets
industriels les déchets ménagers demande
de plus en plus de place sur terre mais
l'impact de l'humanité sur la planète ne
se limite pas à côté chez disons que
vous tirer au pistolet sur un vase ce
dernier explose cela ne veut pas dire
que vous avez cassé le vase avec votre
doigt mais vous avez utilisé votre doigt
jetons mais il est donc tout à fait
possible qu'on ait appuyé sur la détente
s'est déclenché un processus que nous ne
comprenons toujours pas pleinement
jetons préhistoire
les gens pollue de plus en plus la terre
et les océans gaspille l'eau brûlent des
combustibles fossiles détruisent faune
et flore
qu'arrivera-t-il à la terre lors de
cette nouvelle ère de l'humanité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]